hey what's up guys my name is Samuel
Leeds property investor and entrepreneur
this week's thoughtful Thursday I've got
a very good friend of mine on the show
known him since I was six years old we
were best friends at school Eliot
Spencer welcome to the show man thank
you for having me on the show it's great
to be here me and you go back a long way
right we do we do we there at school
when we were six what did you think of
me as a kid um he was a little [ __ ] oh
wow
you never told me that wait you wait
until you want a football first things I
tell me you thought I was a little [ __ ]
no and I love Joe he was like a big
brother tonight you have someone that I
looked up to we had a great life at
school I love school but now you're you
were you're you're a great friend of
momentum even even we were six years old
I love Jess and we were at best mate
same same age pretty much within a month
and when you moved to Wales when Wales
Wales wherever and then you can't about
your own life we didn't really see each
other much at school you know people
just drift away that they do we did keep
in contact yeah and you just have a
different life though because you went
into like that car you've worked at
carplay car sales predominantly I got
into property what did you think I
remember we were about 17 and I don't
know if you remember this but I was
there holding a napkin in pencil
explaining to you how I was about to buy
my first house with no moment I remember
well what did you make of it or did you
think that's amazing good for you did
you through you skeptical what did you
think of what I was doing with my life I
didn't understand it did you know I
didn't understand it but I knew if
anyone could pull it off you could and
all I went in that way I don't know a
lot of my friends I thought my friends I
thought I was crazy going sponsored yeah
yeah I thought it was nuts like some
people will be thinking why you Samuel
spending three grounds for ground fire
groans
paying these property mentors and going
on going down these these scabby courses
mm-hmm but then I'm thinking the same
people that were saying that were going
to university mm-hm and paying forty
thousand pounds to learn about drama
mm-hmm so they can go and end up in a
job in McDonald's yeah like come on
well I'm learn that about finances you
didn't go to drama school
cutting a nighlok about friends did yeah
I wouldn't I won't name them but they
went to university to study stuff now
they're gonna be wrong if you if you
want a job if you want to be a doctor if
that's your goal you've got you've got
to go to your on yeah you got to learn
you got a train but it but if you want
to be if you want if you go to
university just because like art world
it's just but why is it socially
acceptable to spend forty thousand
pounds to go to art school to learn
about drama and it's not for seventeen
year old to go study finances and
property Jim Rohn said self education
will earn your fortune formal education
will make you a living why is formal
education so accepted because we brought
up in a world where we taught and we're
told to go to university aim high
education education education came in
high it's not aiming high but it's just
the world that we live in but why are we
discouraged to to educate ourselves in
investments and property and and
finances because the government don't
want it in the bounce don't want it
don't want what they don't want people
to be successful you know I'll be great
there people don't won't be able to be
crippled by death yeah because if you
don't they've got a hold on them yeah I
do I spy agree with that you go to the
bank and asked for a loan to get married
hmm belt same no problem mmm-hmm you you
go and you ask for a loan - best in
property that says cubits yes - yeah how
can it be how can it be okay to spend it
on getting married on your wedding day
that will be gone and then you got a 50%
chance ending in divorce anyway mm-hmm
how's that fine but investing in a
property is risky anyway so what did you
do your life after after school so I
left school I went into sales mainly
cook mainly car sales it was a good job
it was very well paid but that was all
it was it was it was well paid I was a
digital number I was an employer I was a
I was a number on a board I remember you
were working last 60 70 hours a week I
was working like a dog I don't remember
I hope you don't mind sharing come on
I went on because I started out
seventeen about my first half 17 21 I'm
completely financially free
I just
literally bought like my 12 house mm-hmm
and I was doing really well and then all
my friends that took the mickey out of
me and now working at home serve on 19
grand a year after finishing you know
studying archaeology mm-hmm like what
the heck but there was a few people at
school that I was friends with like
yourself will messmates the school
there's a few people and now I'm
financially free I'm not bored but
making a loan is boring mm-hmm so I'm
saying to you hey Elliot
Jordan hook up oh yeah I'm working all
right cool and we weren't really seeing
each other too much I had now at time
then I remember saying to you I'm in the
same Elliott I know one word school you
talk about I going to cut all your stuff
should we go to California we'll win a
Ford Mustang and we'll just go all
around the different parts of California
we can go downtown Las Vegas and stuff
just like take a month off it'll be a
blast and you a lot of man I couldn't I
couldn't possibly afford that I couldn't
afford it not gonna get the time off
work but then I got what are you saying
he can't afford things and I understand
let's go to Barcelona and I offered to
pay mm-hmm and what did you say I said
let's go but I need to make sure we get
this all off work and then what did your
boss say I think my boss said no he did
say no and now I'm thinking this sucks
and that was almost the start of my
property training education hmm because
I remember thinking my friends are
boring because there's they're [ __ ]
to their bosses which you were mm-hmm
I'm like my sibling let me just teach
you about property you can learn and
then we can go we can travel together
and and now you're obviously in probably
say I am and you've learned a whole
bunch of new skills we did go to
Barcelona I did go to Barcelona and you
and you paid yourself prepared myself I
got the time off work and like you've
done hundred I think was it how many
deals did you do in just last year I
think it was 251 the total amount
like what to you 5150 right and you're
not keeping these these are bills that
you'll get an investor yeah but still
dude now you do super well talk to me
about the skills that you've learned
because you're happier now not only
finances but your life has changed
dramatically since I bought it's the
props again yeah we've lost weight hmm
you'd better look it thank you
you've lost a bit of hair a lot of that
but dude talk talked with him talk to so
I left school 16 wedding to sales it's
corporate corporate car sales and no
sales so a lot of people can be it can
be can be a lot of things one can be
sleazy pushy and everything it was
really yes car sounds very sleazy very
pushy
I felt like pulling people's pants down
really really well you were selling porn
up selling cars why didn't feel like
that because I was pushed and I was
driven by targets yeah I was pushed and
I was driven but Commission hurt so the
more that I've sold the more that irons
yeah and I didn't care what assault okay
if slowly walked into my full court they
were buying a car so you were a good
salesperson but you were the reason that
people didn't like salespeople yes push
a pushing target driven yes okay and
you're working long hours for long hours
yeah all right it was alright but you
didn't have lots of money to save and
stuff and no never had savings and then
what happened so it was what three years
ago now we're looking at I came when you
crash course yeah and I ended up taking
a job for chemical bond over in high
uh-huh which you were yeah and I passed
and on you talk menu taught me
everything I know and within 12 months
I'll pass 250 dealers but the crazy
thing is as well is when you came in
your biggest the biggest hardship for
you was a wrong view of sales I thought
yes because before sales meant to you
making people buy yeah that sales it was
taking him on her taking the nose take
your money which is true to a point but
we we really get to go through this
mm-hmm what's your definition of sales
now providing somebody with a product
that they want that will fix a problem
yeah Fitz buck man that's it so sales is
filing someone there's a stuck it's now
demands and needs what do you need what
do you want yeah I've got this product
this product could knock on it so what
is all the stuff or got a desire to go
somewhere yeah and then you're coming in
providing them a solution to then fit
that okay that makes sense so and you've
as a result of that you've sold a lot of
property mm-hmm everything in a way is
kind of sales because money comes from
people yeah the houses that you rent out
yourself you need to sell the tenant on
the idea of moving it and that's where
my life has changed God cause because
you're always selling everybody is a
sales person in this world okay I was
selling before because I wanted
something yeah I wanted something from
them yeah now it's they want something I
provide them with it and it's not about
what I want
what what's in it for me it's not what's
in it for them so what are you selling
them we're selling will was selling
property that was gonna get them to a
point in their lives where they wanted
to be financially so property it's it's
it's a vehicle it's a product that
you're gonna make a lot that you don't
make money from the thing is that even
when you're talking to a motivated
seller mm-hmm you think all the
motivated seller is selling you the
property but you're selling the
motivated seller on giving the property
to you at a reduced rate mm-hmm yeah
everything yourselves give me something
give me some sales techniques think it
talk to us about some of the things that
you've learned practically on because
although now I know you you sell a lot
and also as well something really
interesting is that we have a lot of
people that go through our training
programs yeah kind of like you did they
wanna be part of my bigger mission which
is helping other people do that what I
feel now is I'm giving back yeah I'm
offering a product and that's helping
people because you're changing people's
lives your packaging deals you're also
you I guess you could say sell even it's
totally not like sales but you're you're
a training probably training advisor
where you help package programs for
people hmm which is awesome mm-hmm
so if anyone's watching this that one
to do my advanced training my further
training the way you have to where you
speak to people about it you're one of
those guys I am what you love to do it
why you love it so much because I'm
seeing people change their lives
yeah I'm seeing people they ring me up
that speaks me about the Academy I've
talked to them about the Academy they're
nervous is how I help them through it
I'll get them enrolled as six months
later the call to me give me a massive
life five and say EDX the best thing
I've ever done
you've changed my life bro mmm I'm now
owning one of your property you have now
got X amount of properties in my
portfolio and if I hadn't have come and
spoken to you or had done this was it
like working with me under the working
for you I won't work for anybody else
anymore I really wouldn't I don't know
working for you I love work for this
company what's different about this
company against other companies is the
ethos and the beliefs and you give and
the fact that this company gives back
and it helps people because you see
although although technically I know I
know you have a job you could argue
within our company as well as doing
other stuff and your own things but you
really don't have a job no we really
you're pop you're a team mate within our
mission right this is a family yeah so
sales techniques then if you're selling
whether whether you're selling a program
a deal an investor I'm giving you a deal
a tenant on moving in probably most
people are watching this they think they
can relate to the most it's probably
selling a deal and so a new packages and
salt more deals than just about anybody
on the planet talking about its deal
package a deal package in here it's one
of the easiest things to sell because
the product is the product that the
props that you selling don't want it
yeah so that's the first thing that they
want what you've got to offer as long as
it offers a good return on investment
mm-hmm and it's in a good areas demand
and you can prove it you can back it up
with proof so first thing is you'll sell
it so first thing is finding that deal
finding the deal doing the research job
that's crucial
okay so once you've got the deal you
then got a salad yeah how do you sell it
you send it out to a database of
investors get their database and network
it massive load yeah social media it's a
massive one
yeah I guess you don't need a massive
list you know thing one or two people
that will buy yes it's the right people
yeah okay so you go out and you find the
they'll call you then drop an email out
to your contacts yeah and what does the
email say are you selling when you start
selling me um let's just bust the myth
of selling a minute you said it already
when we say selling we're not talking
about get that money no you know we're
talking about helping someone super when
you believe in your product or service
first so you have to qualify yes you've
got a quality for you cuz you don't
wanna you wasting your time on theirs so
alright so what is the email side so on
the email you've got the details of the
products of the outfitter where it is
the location the money's going to return
if there is if there's any work that
needs to be done well addressed and no
no you don't give the full address
okay so you're gonna hold some stuff
back why because you don't want all the
odd work that you've put in doing all
the research all the due diligence for
them to go find the property online and
then go beyond your button to the agents
I'm just going to show you're it sure
you end up in a bidding war so if you
are giving them the full details you'll
need like an NBA yes
non-disclosure agreement yeah if you're
not having an NBA then you're not going
to give the theory that all details
enough firm to make an informed decision
on the basis that you've done the due
diligence which is where there's a
massive element of trust involved yeah
so these people at the first don't know
me yeah they know the company they don't
know me you've got to build the trust
you've got to build the rapport there's
something like massive in car sales well
you've gotta build the trust you've got
to build the rapport and when you get on
with them and when they trust you when
they believe you and when they believe
in the product that you sell it yeah
nine times out of ten what happens
property from you and it turns out to be
a now if it's about property you just
give them them when you back okay
so there's that's got to be some kind of
a contract yes you always get this on a
contract when they said she's getting so
I'm a contract and I said I want to go
ahead with it
yeah and for whatever reason if it's if
it's my fault if it's our fault that the
property's bad then yeah we always give
now I know it from the come on the
compliant size and and on the contracts
and all that stuff that's something that
I already helped you a they took care of
does you love in my company yeah
but let's talk about the sale let's talk
about how you actually get people
because what a lot of people are finding
is that
really good deals and drunk remove
investor's but they cannot get their
investor to make a decision anything
tell me what you do I ask them where
they are now at that point of life you
know what's money look like what where
are you where you're at what are you
trying to achieve what do you need from
me
so before you so that's very clever
because instead of you saying to them
okay well this house is fantastic and
these are the benefits and this is the
you actually flipping the cards and
you're saying well you tell us what
you're looking for yeah how what kind of
property would you like yeah okay so
you're not only are you pre-qualifying
them I'm making sure that before you
actually close the deal you're closing
the deal to the right person
yep but you're also making them have to
sell themselves to you a little bit
right which is genius okay so they give
you the information then yeah I've got
20 grand in the bank I've got a mortgage
in principle I'm ready to go then what
when they've got the money in the bank
mortgage bridge will improve everything
then that's when the transaction
completes an it's literally a case of do
you on the property or not this is what
it's going to get you I'll send her over
the terms and conditions on the terms of
additions it will state the property
details they not then they come back to
you with signs of terms than what they
want and then when they tell you
assuming that it fits you just assume
that they want it yeah okay so talk to
me like this a little bit of roleplay I
kind of you're the master of that okay
so okay I just so you email probably
looks really good I'm interesting
getting some more details okay what
details would you like what are you
looking for I'm looking for something
that gives me a 20% return on investment
hands off power team all employees are
after they mess around
okay well the phenomenal news is this
deal that you've ramped up about has got
all that in place okay so can I ask you
a few questions
yeah brilliant out soon you're looking
to move on this okay genius
it's the problem Jack I mean start away
okay would you bother the right props
you today can I talk to explain what
you're doing why so genius yeah you know
what you doing I'm doing pre-close yeah
talk to me about you just you just pre
closed me I just yes so before you go
into the details of property I want to
know that they're ready they're gonna
buy that
whether you're also creating a pattern
yeah of yeses yeah okay people watching
this some people won't quite realize and
they'll be thinking you know why can't I
sell deals and the reason is because
they didn't run things
third thing you did genius you're asking
me the questions which means that you're
in control no sales people just tell
them about the product right it's got
three bedrooms and there's a really good
crowd in your place all that's going to
do is mean that that person is going to
ask you more questions
mm-hmm and then more questions and you
become totally opened draw where was
you're asking me the questions
oh yeah the property was right yeah I
guess I could I could move a bit away
brilliant well I've got this props that
you're running well today so I'm get on
you're interested I have got a couple
other people all over the parties
interested or so now you're create
urgency yes because you're telling me
that there's other people interested
would you say that it wasn't true
no okay so you sent out an email to a
list of people my phones blowing up sure
my phones because you build it the right
way around first you've got the
investors ready mm-hmm
but then the fact that your phones
blowing up it gives you good positioning
to be able to create urgency inside look
there are other people that are
messaging me about this hmm
in other words you gotta make your
decision mm-hmm you should just secure a
deal 20% below market value with a power
team in the area which which which could
make your grand a month because you
could do it as a high tomorrow and you
just put an offer forward to the seller
and the seller said yes I'll accept your
offer
hmm well they know what they want
documents the state says it wants
documents yeah
they can't miss around I can't mess
around okay so is it evil other people
trusted okay okay so click continue
right so the fee is X amount okay three
thousand pounds three thousand pounds
plus vatt
okay our I'll send you over our refund
policy and our deeds and our all of our
details and the contracts if you please
read through the contracts and then come
back to me with it signed and documented
I will date it I will then come back to
you and take your payment
wouldn't you've then secured and paid
the payment the properties then yours
and I won't sell it to anybody else
all right sure and then what would you
say that I want to put a time frame on
it so I'm going to say when can you come
back to me now heads in terms yeah terms
yes so I'm gonna get you all the
documents and over read through them so
they're back to me they don't want to
avoid shooting the video is yours you've
got tech message which right now you've
got 10 minutes otherwise I'm thinking
all the phone somebody else yeah
boy another great word I like is the
words how soon something right now how
soon would you be able to read that I
can bring it right away
awesome listen it's now 329 would you be
able to do me a favor and get that back
before 4 o'clock and then we can get it
all wrapped up today and it's gonna be
yours boom these corner lines so ok I
love that
so what's next man what's next for
Elliot Spencer in life yeah Wow because
what he did so much like personally
you've got shape for a start
how much have you lost in the last year
five and a half stone dude that's
incredible man
its massive inspiration mm-hmm what's so
what's next what's next I want to keep
developing he I read a lot of books I
read a lot of the books like Grant
Cardone
and I want to better myself as a
salesperson I'm good I'm very good what
I believe there's always room for
improvement
yeah and I've got a lot of good mentors
around me Russell Leeds
Alastair the books that I'm reading the
people who don't see Tony rock which
we're going to see him last year yeah
and I thought you know you did you did
you taught me you pay for they all are
good the thing is some people think it's
just about the money yeah
oh I want to get so much money I want to
get but really true happiness comes from
just being a better person I know that's
one of the things that you've captured
really well your honor you're on a
journey of growth of personal growth I'm
just going to keep doing what I'm doing
final words of wisdom to people that
might be watching this video
they don't wanting to get better
themselves we have better of sales start
a property portfolio in the currently
got nothing what what are your words of
wisdom
just do it just just just do it is I had
a massive opportunity handed to make two
years ago with yourself and there was a
lot so if sports just just do it just do
it read a lot pick a mentor grow as many
mentors as you can
then what keep watching YouTube channels
keep twisting these guys on YouTube he
will still these speakers and just go
with it it's all I've ever done there's
us to use it my last two years and it's
been an absolute roller coaster you know
it wouldn't change it for the world
and when you started out and they you
were earning a decent wage in car sales
yeah but when you started out in
property yeah
you didn't have savings no but no people
think you've got enough money but what
you really have to have is what desire
yeah so it's want to do well in ours
yeah whatever it takes me to however it
takes knowledge network these are things
that you need why won't be on them oh
yeah beer yes mum say yes do it and work
the rest out afterwards
yeah which is always a work and we've
got a lot of exciting stuff going on
right now we've got a Lowe's it'll be
another video coming out thanks for
coming on the show bro Thank You
friendship thank you all right bro hope
you guys enjoyed that him from Elio
Spencer you let us know in the comments
what you liked best and what you want to
see next time on thoughtful Thursday and
in the meantime I'll see you next time
[Music]
all right
hey my name is Samuel Leeds welcome to
this week's thoughtful Thursday which is
where we just kick back relax and we
talk about life property and board heads